[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight what a weird day it was in
Washington hard as it may be to believe
two weeks after the release of the
Muller report but on Capitol Hill
tonight they are still yelling about
it's as if the most exhaustive federal
investigation in a generation never even
happened it's as if the Russia collusion
story was completely real and not a
ludicrous hoax pushed by ruthless
partisans
it's as if facts no longer matter at all
only emotion and ambition and the
overriding will to power these
apparently are the new rules in
Washington the Attorney General William
bar turned them today as he was summoned
before the Congress angry Democrats
interrogated Bar but the letter he wrote
in March summarizing the Moller report
now you might wonder why anyone would
care about that letter the entire Mullah
report was subsequently released not
long after the letter that report is now
available online anyone can read it you
can read it if you want you can draw
your own independent conclusions about
what it says you don't need Bob bars
help his summary is irrelevant now
partisans on cable TV are pretending
otherwise but let's be clear let's be
very clear what they are giving you is
opinion it is not fact and they should
be honest about that the bar letter
means nothing again that is fact not
opinion so what was the point of today's
hearings well part of the point was to
allow people like mazie Hirono to
perform for the cameras just a few years
ago virtually nobody outside of Hawaii
had ever heard of mazie Hirono she was
considered forgettable even by the
standards of the US Senate now she's a
celebrity on CNN technically she remains
unimpressive
she has never written a single bill
you've heard of but when the cameras
roll mazie Hirono comes alive she'll
repeat literally anything her staff puts
on a card enhancer no matter how extreme
and stupid it might be here she was
today mr. Barr now the American people
know that you are no different from Rudy
Giuliani or Kellyanne Carl
or any of the other people who
sacrificed sir once decent reputation
for the grifter and liar who sits in the
Oval Office you once turned down a job
offer from Donald Trump but when we read
the report we knew Robert Miller's
concerns were valid and that your
version of events was false you told
senator chris van hollen that you didn't
know if Bob Muller supported your
conclusions but you knew you lied but I
wasn't surprised you did exactly what I
thought you'd do is why I voted against
your confirmation but now we know more
about your deep involvement and trying
to cover up for Donald Trump being
Attorney General of the United States is
a sacred trust you have betrayed that
trust
America deserves better you should
resign reading it right off the card
handed the card here you go
she'll read it deep involvement in a
cover-up now remember Bill Barr wrote
his letter on March 24th the full malo
report was released on April 18th that
means that for three and a half long
weeks America was under the false
impression that Donald Trump was not a
Russian agent to Cory Booker of New
Jersey that sounds like a sophisticated
disinformation campaign run by you
guessed it Russian agents we have here
documented a level of coordination with
a foreign adversary sharing polling data
and and and we're seem to be and your
conduct seems to be trying to normalize
that behavior and that's why I think we
are in such a serious moment that could
that is eroding the cultures of this
democracy and the security of democracy
and so let's just get into some of this
specifically eroding the cultures of
this democracy now we can only guess as
to what that might mean
Spartacus did not explain himself but if
you actually wanted to undermine
democracy probably the first thing you
would do is ignore the expressed will of
voters and you would instead create
sideshows designed to deflect attention
from your incompetence and
lack of interest in what the actual
population wanted or in the president
they elected or in the priorities that
they expressed to pollsters and at the
ballot box you'd ignore all of that
instead you pretend that some irrelevant
letter that Bob Barr wrote back in March
was more important than all of it more
important than the opioid crisis were
the ongoing invasion from Central
America over our southern border then
you'd want mazie Hirono on TV as much as
possible screaming about a cover-up that
way maybe nobody would notice that the
roads were crumbling or the suicide rate
was rising or that you for reasons you
could never really explain were intent
on wasting still more money and still
more lives on pointless wars in Syria or
Yemen or Venezuela you continue whip up
hatred and division in the population
needless to say nothing works as well as
that does so you'd employ slogans like
white privilege or toxic masculinity to
make people really hate each other over
time the population would be so
mesmerised and afraid they might not
even notice that you were wrecking the
country yep if you wanted to undermine
democracy that's exactly what you would
do